I guess the big thing for me and I'm
really excited to coach Camden like you
know what just getting to know him being
around him seeing the way that he's
rehab and the way he's taking this
seriously I think I think if he does
this right and we do this right now his
best football is ahead of him and so you
know I didn't know him before coming
there and I've really enjoyed my
interactions with him and so you know I
have a job to do and it's not to start
talking about like six months from now
it's about right now making sure that we
get cam healthy for this fall cuz if
he's healthy there's really no questions
about who he is or what he can do so
just making sure that that's really our
focus right now getting that in place
but I felt like coming here I wanted to
make sure people knew like I'm I really
want to coach this god I really like
this guy and I really like the way he's
approaching his rehab and the way he's
doing things that's Panthers coach mat
row from the Scouting Combine when he
says coming here he wants to make people
understand that in hindsight Cris and
they're not the first team to do this
they had a strategy they had a plan
they had a ruse they were trying to
convince people I believe that they were
going forward with cam in an effort to
persuade someone to try to trade for of
course and there were no takers there
were no bites and eventually they ripped
off the band-aid a couple of weeks ago
and cut Cam Newton and yesterday the GM
Marty her knee met with reporters
pre-draft conference that's gonna happen
all the time as we approach the draft in
16 days her knee would not get into
specifics when asked why they made the
decision to move on from Cam Newton
dangling him in an effort to trade him
before they cut him all her knee said is
that was probably one of the most
difficult decisions as soon as we
decided to trade in my called cams
representatives and told them we were
gonna start calling teams to see if
there was interest but they never got
into the why they were ready to move on
from Cam Newton and and look maybe
there's a lot of issues a lot of reasons
maybe they're trying to be respectful of
Cam Newton but the bottom line is this
continues to be confusing
it continues to be confounding and the
fact that no one's been linked to this
guy in the two weeks that he's been
available is amazing to me Chris I
understand no one can do a proper
physical of Cam Newton but to hear that
no one's even interested pending the
opportunity to do the physical is what's
amazing to me well I you know first off
okay let's say into the first question
but with Carolina you know why did they
not want
Cam Newton or whatever it may be you
know I guess the contract situation sure
they've seen them beat get beat up the
last few years so they do have a better
knowledge of his medical history and
where his body's at and I think
ultimately the way Matt rule and new
offensive coordinator Joe Brady you know
they want to coach their team yes they
want to start a new era with their
imprint not the old regimes imprint
which would be Cam Newton but also I
don't think Cam Newton necessarily fits
that style of offense either and I think
they recognize that Teddy Bridgewater
came from that style of offense so Joe
Brady and Matt rule like that now the
other aspect is teams being interested
yeah Carolina has got a free pass
because of Koba 19 and there hasn't been
enough talking head shows but they
screwed over Cam Newton there's no other
way to say it they totally screwed over
the best player in the history of their
franchise and yes who else everybody all
the seats are filled other than the Los
Angeles chargers and they're telling us
they're going forward with Tyrod Taylor
so they're it's hard to find a spy and I
don't know if he'll find one until
training camp starts now yeah I agree
with you and then he's definitely not
gonna find a spot until he can go
somewhere and have that physical where a
team can properly assess where that foot
is where the ankle is where the shoulder
may be and remember last year he's in
the process of trying out a new throwing
motion we forgot about that once he
injured the foot that derailed him after
only two games Cam Newton had an
Instagram live session with Chris Paul
recently and cam said I'm a fish out of
water I've never not known anything
other than the Carolina Panthers and now
it's like I want God to direct my path
and put me in a position where I can
thrive and be myself on top of that it's
still about becoming better Chris I
don't know who's gonna emerge somebody
surely is going to emerge the guy is too
good if he's healthy he has to have a
job somewhere I still think the dolphin
speaking of fish out of water even
though dolphins aren't fish they're
aquatic mammals keep an eye on the
Dolphins keep and I'm just saying keep
an eye on him Chris yeah I know your
guts usually right I would be I mean it
makes sense I just would be shocked so
we'll see where it goes but we'll be
back at pft right after this
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports